this is the big lie that you have spoken
out against for a long time you should
feel very vindicated over the pass well
it's pretty vindicated lately because
the the big lie we've always heard is oh
these college campuses these are just a
bunch of idiots just wait until they get
out into the real yeah yeah well I'm
looking around the real world now and
I'm seeing the consequences of those
college campuses as the buildings are
burning down all around the country this
is the Rubin report and I'm Dave Rubin
don't forget to subscribe to that
YouTube channel we've got over there and
click the notification bell and joining
me today is the host of the Michael
Noel's show on The Daily wire and a
best-selling author Michael Knowles
welcome to the Rubin report Dave thank
you for having me how is we not done
this before something doesn't seem right
here like the universe is sort of lining
up right now but how did this not a lie
I like that it took a pandemic for us to
really do and I don't are we allowed to
shake hands I wanna shake head can we
I'm gonna shake your hand on camera
because you know this yeah I think what
the rest of the world doesn't know this
on Super Tuesday which was what was that
February was that March it's like March
2nd it was a while ago
that was like right at the beginning of
Corona yeah Super Tuesday I'm with you
guys at the Daily wire just as Coronas
bubbling up you are the last hand that I
shook as I was walking out of there I
shake Shapiro's hand I shake Levens hand
whoever else in the crew and then I walk
out of there you're the last one that I
shake and then we went into lockdown the
next day so short of David I have not
touched another name the last one and
yeah according to the latest medical
science yeah if you ever get coronal
it's my fault well the best part the
best part of that is that then it turned
out that I guess a few days before you
were at where were you use at CPAC you
were at CPAC and occurred out somebody
at CPAC shook somebody's hand about and
I'm like man I'm gonna get coronavirus
now because Noel's was that CPAC that's
right shook my hand
but yet we're both here and we're both
healthy we both survived it is so funny
cuz right after that the reason that
became a big story at CPAC is I was
there with senator Cruz and we were
this this live show yeah we're in the
green room and there were there were a
lot of important people in the
administration there was like Kellyanne
Conway it was Ronnie McDaniel as the
head of the GOP all these in this very
small room and one guy tested positive
for coronavirus so all of a sudden you
have all these people locking down
quarantine for weeks and weeks and I
thought I've just ruined the Reuben
report because I'm the last guy that he
touched but not only the Reuben report
if any of this had had a veracity that
they told us it was gonna have you would
have taken out the daily wire you would
have taken out half of Los Angeles and
yet we're all here well because we found
the cure you know we found the cure to
coronavirus which it turns out is
nationwide race riots race yes it's
right I thought it might be
hydroxychloroquine I thought it could be
they maybe get a vaccine no turns out
race riots that's secured to the virus
although you're being slightly sarcastic
there you know we've had public
officials that have said that that has
literally said if we get the second wave
of Crona it will not be because of the
disease itself it will be because of
racism this is what one of the health
commissioners of New York City said not
not just one it was this this letter
that came out a couple weeks ago I think
it was about 1200 over 1200 public
health officials who said there are
there are riots and it's a riot is that
there were protests going on right
peaceful very peaceful social justice
protests against racism those should be
encouraged from a public health
perspective but the protests that went
on a few weeks before against the
lockdowns those must be discouraged
because they are mostly white and I
frankly I don't even know that's true
yeah and this was the kicker they said
from our perspective as scientists we
know that white supremacy which is
totally a real thing white supremacy is
a public health threat that exacerbates
coronavirus this was a shock to me I
didn't we don't know that much about the
virus but we do know that how do you
feel being a pundit in the stupidest
time
I've been thinking a lot about this I
think this is the best time to be a
pundit to be in politics because we've
been living in this fiction for for an
actually a number of years now yeah
which is that there is science right and
science with a capital s trademark over
the e is you can't argue with science
science tells you what to do we bow down
and pay obeisance to the god of science
and what we're finding out is a lot of
this science is not so certain it's
actually a little bit more political and
all that I mean obviously in coronavirus
they've basically admitted it are you
telling me that the w-h-o the World
Health Organization could potentially
occasionally possibly be wrong about
things I would never want to contradict
the Chinese Communist Party we are on
you too about a yes I don't know exactly
but this is the issue but II but that
sort of thing where it's like I mean
because we're so in the same world here
again that we have to believe these
people the second they say something
even though two weeks later they say the
complete reverse right related to masks
or whatever it is and then we are doing
this on YouTube and I'm sure they're
gonna suppress the views on this but the
simple truth is YouTube said you can't
contradict the w-h-o which contradicts
itself all the time right I mean what
the hell are we doing here you see it on
the masks they say the Surgeon General
the United States said do not buy masks
there they will harm people if you buy
the masks don't buy masks then later you
have to buy the masks the disease will
be spread on surfaces the disease won't
be spread on surfaces the disease will
be spread by asymptomatic people the
disease won't be spread by asymptomatic
people right the list goes on and on and
actually it gets to a distinction you
talk about a lot the distinction between
say progressives or leftists and
classical liberals right well what the
progressive project has been telling us
for a hundred years now is forget about
politics
forget about debate and persuading your
fellow citizens and engaging in
questions and making ethical choices
just pick some experts in lab coats they
are going to find the indisputable
answer they're gonna tell you all how to
live your lives and even if they
contradict themselves the next day we
just have to do what they say and I
think what we're beginning to learn now
is no we actually have a right to speak
about this - we're not just gonna
blindly follow you what do you think
this psychological under
pinning of that is with progressives
because I get it I've thought a lot
about this I wrote about this like what
do you think it is about the progressive
mind that they pretend they're
anti-authoritarian all the time and yet
they love authoritarian voices actually
all their policies are authoritarian all
the every time there's a study that
proves what they want then that's the
right study and everybody else is the
racist study or something like that but
do you think there is like a
psychological reason to it I do I think
it actually it's it's a philosophical
and a psychological reason and it goes
back to Karl Marx and it actually goes
back to this idea of science so if you
go all the way back to the word science
science just refers to knowledge it
comes from the Latin word for knowing
things right and yet now the word
science has been minimized it's been
truncated into this little tiny aspect
of material inquiry and empirical
inquiry right so everything else that we
had we have to say that knowledge is
kicked out of that and what Mark said
was he discovered a science of history
mhm
and this is what progressives say it's
right there in the word progressive is
we're progressing towards something it's
inevitable Barack Obama used to always
quote Martin Luther King jr. who would
always say the arc of the moral universe
is long but it bends toward justice
Payton basically meaning we're
inevitably hurtling toward this
progressive utopia and you you can stand
in the way for a little bit but you're
not really gonna stop it and so then
don't forget history will judge you and
hiss you'll be on the wrong side of
history right all of this language
basically turns politics into a science
and the reason it does that is so that
you can't disagree with it and that's
the science is always always right you
could never disagree with it and what
we're learning now is that was just an
excuse that was a facade to cover up
their political choices and so I think
the authoritarian impulse their comes
because they know that we're going to
paradise they see the utopia right ahead
of us and so if you stand in the way of
utopia you can only be one of two things
really evil or extremely stupid and
either way we shouldn't be listening to
you and the funny thing about this is
they think the word utopia means the
best place but it doesn't mean that the
word actually means no place it doesn't
exist and I think a lot of people are
waking up to that well there's a semi
zone in Seattle thank you is there
utopia whatever the hell is going on
there how old are you I don't I'm your
lady never tells
okay you're you're a young fella yeah
out there in the political world and I
always find it interesting when when I
meet younger conservatives so especially
now at college when I meet younger
conservatives because I think yeah
although I do think this is changing now
for at least a decade really more than a
decade probably a couple decades to be a
young conservative was like you're just
sort of this dorky stuffy whatever
you're a nerd you you you know you care
about numbers you don't know anything
about culture you're not funny you don't
like comedy or any of these things were
you always a conservative and how do you
see that sort of changing right now cuz
I really see it changing on I see it I
mean I think we're we're in the midst of
it changing pretty radically I basically
came out of the womb smoking cigars but
pardon Harry wearing penny loafers I did
go through must've been a difficult
birth it was tough my mother's a saint
you know there's no question 1996 I
campaigned around my first-grade
classroom for Bob Dole for president I
was the only person in America yeah
defending Bob Dole yeah I did that's
above Dolman no I I don't know why Allah
I think I liked him cuz he was a war
hero Clinton was a draft dodger but I
don't know I had this conservative
impulse I went through a liberal phase
it was short was Mike maybe 14 15
something like that second and third
grade second or third grade yeah and
then I totally found myself
what was that liberal phase for you
though you know I think it came about
because I grew up in a very liberal
place I went to a very liberal school
all my friends were liberals it was
simply where non from from New York from
Westchester all right you're from that's
right right yeah and it's just not
acceptable it wasn't even possibility to
be a conservative and so I went along
with that then I started slowly
questioning things I mean I was an
atheist from 13 to 23 basically a
10-year period there and those religious
questions tie into some political
questions but I think over time I it
became clear to me that there were more
possibilities and this is something I
actually have a lot of pity for left
wingers who live in left-wing places and
go to left-wing institutions which is
they don't know what they don't know see
conservatives do know we see the other
side of the argument 24/7 you can't help
it and so because your ideas are
constantly under attack you've got to
refine them you've got to change them
maybe you throw some out maybe you
double down on some the left doesn't
have that that privilege you know and so
I think part of the reason why they
scream and they shriek and they set up
autonomous zones in Seattle and they do
is because they they don't really know
why they think what they think and you
know conservatives we we have the
fortune of being able to to think
through that yeah I mean I've talked
about that a lot because it's like you
have you guys own culture and then on
top of it you also created safe spaces
what do you think was going to happen
when all the people over the last you
know five years
we're yelling at guys like us for
talking about what was going on on
college campuses oh it's just a bunch of
kids yeah you know and it's like
actually you do know that this is
leaking out into society and these
people are graduating and they're
starting to take down institutions
literally but you have young editors at
publishing houses that are getting books
cancelled at the New York Times and the
New York Times has been taking up do you
think this thing is going to destroy
virtually every liberal institution what
so that we have this is the big lie that
you have spoken out against for a long
time you should feel very vindicated
over the pass you know it's pretty
vindicated lately because the big lie
we've always heard is oh these college
campuses these are just a bunch of
idiots just wait until they get out into
the real yeah yeah well I'm looking
around the real world now and I'm seeing
the consequences of those college
campuses as the buildings are burning
down all around the country yeah the
issue with the institution's you bring
up is an interesting one because we've
been told for the past few weeks that
all of these protests are about
institutional racism right but then it
occurred to me the left controls every
major institution in America yeah
control of the media controls higher
education and lower education controls
Hollywood controls big tech controls
administrative government control
basically other than talk radio and some
little parts of the internet the left
controls every institution so if there's
institutional racism whose fault is that
well not only whose fault is it but
they are the ones putting it into the
institutions they are the ones making
its systemic Harvard yeah
Harvard says we want less Asian people
because you guys have had it too good
through hard work and education so we're
going to institute a racist policy I
don't know if you saw it I just tweeted
last night or this morning this thing in
Tacoma Washington we're there now go it
is going to be in practice that if you
have lost your job or need housing
because of kovat they're only going to
help people who identify as people of
color well that makes it easy might have
something I might you know the Sicilian
wiggle room here Yeah right I mean you
see that you saw this with ubereats
right yeah love this one they come out
they say if you're ordering from a
black-owned business whatever that I
don't mean are you gonna measure the
equity here a black on business there's
no delivery fees but if it's a white
owned business there will be no they are
the ones actually injecting racism into
the system of course but but that's the
point you know I it occurred to me I
thought a friend came up to me the other
day said Michael it's almost like they
want us to be racists there the
mainstream media the left they're
ginning up this racial division it's
like they want us to be racist and I
realize they do they actually need you
to be racist because so much of
liberalism is about overcoming this
oppressive past right so the whole story
of liberalism is yeah you can't end it
can't end it's gut you've always got to
be freeing yourself but look around you
remember early on in the riots the
mainstream media tried to blame white
supremacists how many Klansmen are there
in America like for left or something I
don't I didn't see a whole lot of white
hoods out there I saw I saw a white hood
on the governor of Virginia the Democrat
Ralph Northam I didn't see it in the
riots so they they have to either create
this boogeyman or actually try to create
racists if only to have a villain to
then overcome well so when they're going
through these cities destroying
everything we were talking about West
Hollywood which is literally the gayest
place on earth they have rainbow
crosswalks the entire West Hollywood
right now as we tape this is board it up
I used to live there I went there a
couple days ago it is boarded up it
looks like a third-world nation right
and on every sign outside it says be
Ella
the implication being don't destroy our
business will for you black lives
matters but help watch what I can do
here if it was white supremacists that
were rampaging through the neighborhood
wouldn't you be writing like white power
yeah yeah because then you go oh I'm a
white supremacist your whites we
brothers don't don't bust up my business
of course and also it's worth noting
this is Pride Month right so I think or
ego we're not an expert I thought this
was supposed to be the month to
celebrate West Hollywood and the LGBT
community but that I don't if
progressivism changes so fast that now
Pride Month is canceled and now Pride
Month is BLM month what's it gonna be
next year you remember a couple years
ago at Toronto pride when they stopped
BLM stopped the March and said you guys
can't March any further unless you sign
our edict or our whatever it is and and
basically they did and they let the
March and a bunch of us talked about it
and they said oh here you go again here
you guys go again this this issue of the
the intersectional politics it's it's an
interesting one here because you're
almost seeing the return of more of an
old-school Marxism you know for the past
ten years you've been hearing about how
the gay community has something in
common with the trans community just
kind of ironic cuz those two communities
sort of contradict one another either
they're there are individual sexes and
same-sex attraction is having to do with
the two sexes yeah or there's no such
thing as sexes and so that contradicts
the the GE and the LGBT right but those
have something to do together you can
have Gloria Steinem radical feminists
holding hands with Linda Sarsour and
Islamist yeah at the Women's March that
makes sense but now you're seeing that I
think begin to fade away a little bit
into more of an old-school the black
lives matter interest is not the LGBT
interest and the BLM one is going to
take precedence even though all of all
of it comes down to a sort of radical
Marxism and this this is the part that I
think some of the squishy types don't
get because they'll say the word black
lives matter nobody disagrees with that
here's my evidence that nobody disagrees
with it everybody posted the black
square on social media everybody
everybody in government in media in
corporate America in all your friends
they all did it it's no one disagrees
with
that state yeah even people that didn't
want to do it not because they're not
for black live yeah but because they
don't like being bullied into things
they did it too
they did it too but then you look at the
black lives matter website the about us
section and it's not just about black
lives mattering at one point it says we
exist to destroy the quote Western
proscribed nuclear family what what does
that have to do with police brutality or
it's obviously and you can see the
founders of BLM come from radical
leftist organizations which get their
funding from the open societies
foundation which is run by George Soros
that's that's not a conspiracy theory
with no see it's not it's not
anti-semitic to say that I don't even
know how would it be George Soros has
lived his life to basically fund every
young Jew hating thing there is pretty
much right right he would love to have
Israel wiped off the map so the idea
that saying that George Soros funds
these things yeah is anti-semitic is
complete not right it be it becomes what
what the left wants to pretend is that
this is a racial issue primarily and
it's not the left uses race all the time
but it's not you can see when you look
at the about us section of the BLM page
when you look at who's funding it's
primarily ideological and I think
there's some squishy conservatives and
Republicans who want to go along with it
because they they're afraid of being
called racist even when they're not at
all racist but that's a that's a very
bad deal to get into because then you're
accepting radical leftist premises that
are gonna undercut everything you stand
for
in many ways though do you think the
ship has sailed to the point that we
don't have enough power yeah fix this
thing that that you're still a an out
sense and and thoughtful analysis and
people are waking up to it and I do
think a ton of red people are being read
pilled right now because because just
reality is red killing them right I've
got Hollywood lefties friends that are
calling me and they're like where do you
get a gun so it's like so something's
happening here but in many ways do you
think that the destructive force of this
thing yeah has has so infiltrated
everything that nothing can can return
you you've hit the nail on the head
which is we're beginning to see more
people than just
conservatives or classical liberals or
just normal people are seeing
yikes something has gone seriously wrong
here and yet very little is being done
to stop it you see even the President of
the United States more or less all he
can do is tweet about it and people are
saying okay enough tweeting you got to
actually do something but it gets back
to the institutions issue the left
controls the institutions which means
the left controls the levers of power
the only institution that we've got on
the right is talking and so we can talk
until we're blue in the face we can
point out hypocrisy until we're blue in
the face and the left says yeah okay
you've pointed out my hypocrisy I still
have the levers of power I think what is
required now the right and of
conservatives is to take back in actual
institutions of power and perhaps even
more importantly to be willing to
exercise that political power when we
have the abyss that mean rubber meets
the road what are you saying like
actually start separate universities I
mean there are some more conservative
leaning universities and yeah some of
them have thrived in the midst of all
this and University of Chicago although
it's not it's not conservative per se
but they have actually instituted like
an actual defense of free speech and it
probably won't burn as quickly as the
rest of these other places but what do
you actually mean by that like what what
does institution-building look like so
that would be a wonderful thing I mean
unfortunately I could probably count the
conservative universities on one hand
and yeah but and they're really great
universities I guess the the silver
lining in the storm cloud of the
coronavirus lockdown and some of the
riots is that you're seeing a collapse
in many ways of this decrepit
educational infrastructure that that it
not only does not give people an
education and it does not give people an
ability to have a career and it does
saddle them with a lot of debt all it
does is indoctrinate them in a very
modern sort of politics which is not
worth the cost of admission so at least
you're seeing that crumble but I think
there's there's a change in mindset
that's got to come about a little bit
conservatives
maybe in their nature are a little bit
timid mm-hmm and so this is what you'll
you'll hear a lot whenever we're talking
about some kind of political change
we'll say well we conservatives can't do
something about it let's talk about
censorship on social media is a good
example
we can't do anything to rein in the big
tech companies because if if we allow
the government that we control to rein
in the big tech companies then the left
when they get into power they're going
to use that that power to censor us I
understand that in principle but what
that really boils down to is we can't do
anything to stop the left's current
censorship of us because maybe someday
the left will censor us they're already
censoring us it's already so what do you
do then I mean you know I'm big on this
topic and I started a tech company in
the midst of this so what is the right
answer because I understand the original
premise you laid out there and I
understand the counter to that yeah
because it's happening right now and the
simple truth is right this second
although maybe it's maybe it's slightly
altered because of Trump's executive
action but they could do digital
assassinations on all of us today right
now they could shut down daily wire they
could shut me down they could shut down
everybody why like could Trump really
fight that would he really fight that so
what is the answer
so Trump is it a slight disadvantage
because the administrative government
they the bureaucratic state the deep
state whatever you want to call it they
stay around when the elected people come
and go they are there and the elected
people don't have actually a ton of
power over them all the alphabet people
you know that the different agencies one
thing he could do is push an argument
that senator Cruz has been pushing for a
long time which is that section 230 of
the Communications Decency Act creates
this distinction between platforms and
publishers this is what he did though
already right isn't this what the
executive action was yes he took an
executive action through an executive
order but the executive order is more or
less just a letter to the administrative
agency saying please consider doing this
that I hope it works out but ultimately
you know an executive order is often
only as good as the paper that's written
on you could use the DOJ to start
investigating
maybe anti monopolistic courses of
action when it when it comes to big tech
I mean but let's kill you as a
conservative though right I mean yes and
no yes and no I it kills a certain kind
of right-wing consensus that developed
from the 80s and 90s and 2000's which is
that all government action is bad and
you just have to reduce government
action but that's not the whole of
conservative thought you know I mean
that that was a sort of conservative
thought that certainly you've seen
classical liberalism but there's more to
conservatism than that and I think we
want to be able to use the government
well for justice I'm you know it comes
down to a little bit of a disagreement
you see in the origins of our country in
the Federalist Papers what is the end of
government is the end of government
merely to maximize individual liberty we
all love individual liberty
James Madison says in the Federalist the
end of government is justice and so when
you've got these big tech companies
probably breaking the law flagrantly
violating you know certainly some
regulations controlling the flow of
information around the internet in our
republic that doesn't seem very just and
so i think it's perfectly conservative
to use the means at our disposal to stop
that see it's interesting because it's
I'm with you on the argument but I don't
know that the machine that you're
describing that is so broken and corrupt
can do could could do it and I think by
empowering it to do it yeah you will
only make the problem worse it's it's
possible I mean you're running a risk
and this is I think why some
conservatives haven't wanted to to
actually exercise the political power
that we the people give them every so
often and it's because conservatives
naturally are a little bit risk-averse
and I think there is a type of
conservative or right winger
who would rather lose gracefully than
risk being wrong and doing something
wrong and not looking good in the
history books I get it that's a fair
fear is that what you would say about
the never Trump errs or I'm sure you
have more to say about the never Trump
sure I mean you know I I think there
were about two never Trump errs left on
earth you know and you got from and Bill
Kristol a sickly you guys really love
each other yeah and you know I think
like to me it made perfect sense to be
skeptical of Trump in 2016 a lot of
people thought the guy who was a
Democrat or he'd be a left winger so I
kind of get that now I think it's much
harder he's been in many ways the most
conservative president in modern America
and but there are still a few hardcore
people who say no it's so icky I don't
like that we have to
anything to try to accomplish something
but that is the point of politics and
the left is not afraid the left is not
afraid of using the political power that
is given to them by the people I mean
that's what politics is politics is not
abstract politics is not pure philosophy
it's a messy thing there's the line from
Bismarck he says you know we all like
sausage but we don't want to see how the
sausage gets made yeah and so I think
conservatives need to be more willing to
to take a risk to risk how they look in
the history books to risk maybe the
government doing something they don't
like in the future because you can't win
by losing you can't win by we're okay
we're gonna lose this battle we're gonna
lose this issue we're gonna lose this
election but then in some distant future
when everything is perfect and pure then
finally we're gonna win that's not how
politics works so I suspect I know your
answer to this but do you think these
things should be fought on multiple
fronts meaning there can be a more
conservative answer there can be a more
libertarian answer that's more
free-market I mean that's why I started
locals it was like when I I've had this
disagreement with Tucker Carlson on his
show where he wants the government to do
it and I said well I'm gonna try the
free-market side I don't have a problem
with that argument because it's like
maybe we all have to hit it in different
ways look the Prager you guys that you
work with they got into a lawsuit with
YouTube is is Dennis's or I don't want
to speak for Dennis but it's the Prager
you ethos like let's use the law to stop
companies from doing something of course
not but we're all we're all trying to
navigate very murky water and isn't that
the freest market of all is to try all
all of these different solutions to the
problem you're not going to be able to
take down this monstrous left-wing
edifice with one little narrow pure
solution that that one little narrow
pure solution might help but you're
gonna need a lot of different strategies
a lot of different tactics to undertake
and so certainly everything should be on
the table you don't want to do anything
that is objectively wrong I'm not
advocating that any way but if if once
again we shouldn't just burn down the
Google servers I think somewhere in Utah
we shouldn't just go there and and like
mask in the name of social justice yeah
yeah I know we probably shouldn't do
that but but certain
I mean what you've done with locals is a
great example right certainly we can
innovate we can create try to create our
own institutions at least create the
beginnings of our own institutions and
enforce the law that is already on the
books those two things are not
contradictory to one another and
actually if we do enforce the law if we
do have a credible threat of enforcing
the law if we do have a credible threat
of a competitor to one of these
organizations that is going to increase
the likelihood of success on all fronts
you know when you've got something like
a Google and when you add in all the
other tech companies they control the
flow of Internet that is an amount of
power that I don't think anybody who is
who cares deeply about the country or
any of the founding fathers and the
people who've thought about how this
Republic is supposed to work I don't
think they would be comfortable with
that kind of tower being consolidated
whether it's in technically a private
company or not yeah does some of your
belief that these things can be stopped
is there a biblical sort of bedrock
beneath that I mean I always say if
David could be Goliath and made a Dave
to be Google like I really do believe
that that there is we it is so embedded
in us that the little guy can beat the
big guy that that makes me crazy enough
to try to start my own tech company in
the midst of all this yeah that's a
that's such a great point because I
don't know that they can be beaten I
don't know that the destructive left
that has wrecked our institutions and
our political traditions and our our
civil society I don't know that they can
be beaten or beaten in my lifetime but I
do know I should try and I do know I
have no reason not to try I mean I guess
I guess that would be maybe the biblical
basis of it is what do I have to lose
what why would I what would I gain by
playing along and saying things that I
don't believe in and being bullied into
posting whatever I've got a post on
social media if I lose my integrity if I
lose my dignity if I lose the things
that I care about so I have a slightly
more pleasant life that's not a
compelling argument well I think a lot
of people watching this would say well I
don't want to lose my job
yeah and it's a it's a real fear the I
mean I'm sure you get this question all
the time of college campuses
kids will say hey I'm I'm a conservative
I'm a libertarian I believe in certain
things but I'm afraid of saying it in
class should I say it in class or not I
said well are you willing to get the bad
grade what what they're asking is how do
i do what i want to do without paying a
price you can't you can't everything has
a cost for me I've spoken at I've said
what I believe it has cost me certain
things I go to bed at night I'm grinning
ear to ear I sleep like a baby
I I think probably you do too yeah it's
worth it to me but there is a costume
it's interesting because I get that
question all the time where at least
when we were allowed to travel ecologist
remember the old days and I had once
heard ben shapiro obviously give an
answer on that which was that if you're
in college that in your core classes so
meaning if you want to be a doctor in
your core classes you probably shouldn't
speak up because you do need to move
ahead yeah and you don't want to be
screwed but in some of your other stuff
you know like lesbian dance theory like
there you maybe could speak up a little
bit more cuz it probably won't take you
out there was some version of that I'm
not totally sure if that's what he feels
now and for like four or five years ago
what I would say is just suck it up and
get the grade because you want to get
out but about four years ago I
completely changed and I started telling
them absolutely reverse you must speak
up yeah if you don't speak up though
you're if you're in college the world
will never be easier for you you're not
gonna get out of college man you're not
gonna get out of college you have a car
payment and a mortgage and a wife and a
dog and all of these responsibilities
plus all the endless nonsense of the
world and suddenly be like you know I'm
gonna get brave today it'll lose my job
let's roll yeah so you'll never do it so
that that's what I push now but it it
doesn't mean it's easy if actually it
means it's the reverse this is the same
argument as don't worry about the
snowflakes when they get to the real
world no the the real world gets realer
and realer and realer and I understand
prudence is a virtue and politics
changes with time politics is about
circumstances so maybe it made more
sense at one time to keep a little bit
quiet and then you can try to move here
but in terms of how how I would live my
life with the advice I would give no I
would say speak up doesn't mean you need
to go where you're mag ahead every time
you're at the water cooler but but it
does mean if you're asked a question
about your bowl
leaves I would tell people what you
think I I think it's it's a good habit
to get into let's not forget the virtues
or habits and so if you if you practice
them from a young age you're more likely
to be able to practice them at an older
age right and if you don't if you say no
when I turn sixty men then I'm going to
start start practicing the virtues all
right I don't know it's gonna work and
the scarier part is that it's they I
think a lot of young people think oh
it's when I turned 20 - yeah right like
60 we could all accept that a 60 year
old most likely you know although maybe
he's going through like a later midlife
crisis and then maybe is gonna do
something nuts but that probably
involves going to Vegas and you know not
practicing the virtues not right it's
not right you don't have the right
you're not gonna go the virtual thing
I'm kidding you sort of hit on this but
I'm curious what you think the sort of
future how wide a future conservative
tent can be because I'll drop a little
knowledge for you knows I'm like I'm
working on my second book and that's
kind of the direction I'm gonna go with
it that what I'm really it seems to me
that the right broadly speaking has one
the big arguments they've won the
arguments on individual liberty they've
won the arguments on family on belief at
least in the terms of as an organizer of
society maybe not at an absolute
individual level I think we have a
little disagreement on that which
imagine yeah to talk about but that the
right basically got the big stuff right
yeah and what I think is for someone
that's on the more liberal side of that
my job is to kind of make sure that they
never go off the deep end too far right
let's say and start coming around to
like you know trying to get violence out
of video games again like the right used
to try to do right but I know that
there's people on the right that you
know want more of a religious version of
conservatism then there's obviously the
libertarians what do you do you think
that thing can hold because I really
believe that the future of Western
politics not just in America in every
Western nation is a center-right
future I think we're seeing that happen
across the world right now
yes but how why do you think that thing
can be to not to become too big I think
you you don't need to worry as much
about the breadth as the object what
you're fighting against because I do
think that there is a lot of space on
the right but it's not going to be the
same tent that we saw in the Cold War
for instance so you will never find a
greater admirer of
William F Buckley Jr and Ronald Reagan
than me okay I really admire those guys
they fought their battle they were
fighting the Soviet Union and they
cobbled together this coalition that
doesn't make a lot of sense the
Coalition was the social conservative
traditionalist religious right and they
hated the atheism of the Soviet Union
you've got the libertarians you know
practical anarcho-capitalists on one
side right they don't really care about
the religious right argument at all but
they hate the collectivism of the Soviet
Union you've got the Blue Dog Democrats
they don't really care about either of
those two things they care about the
imperial expansion of the Soviet Union
they come together they fight the Cold
War where do you think Reagan fits in
that he's more of like a California
conservative that kind of shifted right
in the midst of all that anybody who
tells you they can analyze Ronald Reagan
is lying to you Ronald Reagan is one of
the most enigmatic figures in American
politics I mean this is a guy he
liberalized abortion laws in California
more than anybody before him and yet he
becomes one of the most pro-life
presidents in American history it's very
I mean I I know that Bill Buckley had a
major influence on bringing Ronald
Reagan over to the right I mean I think
there were a lot of people of his
generation who said they got mugged by
reality and I think that's how you go
from a New Deal Democrat into a
Reaganite conservative that's what's
happening to these people right now yeah
it's happening now and so I think that
made a lot of sense then I don't think
that makes as much sense right now a lot
of that kind of conservatism took on a
very especially in the 80s and 90s and
2000's a an economics first dimension to
it
people just totally said forget about
any cultural issues any social issues
and we're just gonna talk about tax
rates yeah that's what gets people riled
up in the mornings slightly lowering the
marginal tax rate yeah and it's it's
ironic that conservatism devolved into
that because the great philosopher of
conservatism probably the founder of
what you'd call modern conservatism is
Edmund Burke and in the most often
quoted part of the most often quoted
book of his reflections on the
revolution in France he said the age of
chivalry is gone that of Sophos ters
economists and calculators has succeeded
it and the glory of Europe is
extinguished forever and what
do we become Sophos Tirzah to calculate
double down yeah I don't think that the
future of the right is a bunch of
egghead people on spreadsheets talking
about how to more efficiently move
markets I think we we but you don't
think those people are part of it it's
just not the heart of it yeah yeah I
mean I think I think they certainly can
be part of it yeah but I think what
we've got to be motivated by is the
threat and the threat right now is not
the Soviet Union the threat is the woke
left the radical left that is literally
burning down cities as we speak now who
opposes the woke left the religious
right Catholic integralists you know as
far social conservatives you can imagine
and Dave Rubin you know last time I
checked you're not a Catholic integra
list yet at least yeah but you're and
yet both of those groups yeah fit
perfectly together in this tent because
we do have a common foe but the politics
of opposition is often derided but the
politics of opposition works pretty well
it worked well in World War two it
worked well in the Cold War do you think
there's any risk of that in the long
term because that you sort of get these
competing interests I sense this I sense
this more from the from the Catholic
side of this right that they're gonna
align themselves with some people that
they really don't wanna like for this
sort of short term win even if we all
agree that yes that's the thing we gotta
fight but that in the long term that's
not a coalition that can hold well in
the in the long term we're all dead I
guess famous economist said I mean yeah
I think this anxiety comes from some of
the same pathologies that have afflicted
politics in recent years which is that
we think politics is eternal yeah we
think Pollan for the left politics has
become a sort of religion politics is
not eternal politics is just how we all
get along together in this civil society
of ours and politics changes a lot it's
changed a lot in just the last four
years so right now we have this threat
and we've got this coalition that's come
together good yeah let's do it man I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna lose sleep at
night because of some hypothetical
problem if in the future a different
political circumstance arises then I
suspect as always happens the political
coalition's are going to shift again but
let's not lose the fight that we're in
right now because of the hypothetical
fight that we're gonna have in the
future so what would you say then to the
Conservatives who would say all right we
got a guy like Ruben who were aligned
with and all the mugged lefties and the
you know the old-school liberals of blah
blah blah but a decent percentage of
them as you know I describe myself as
progressively pro-choice this is this is
the big one for you guys I get it it's
and by the way it's it's in many ways I
think it's the biggest one but but
alright it's up there let's say in my
book that's the argument I make twelve
weeks and I don't deny it's a life and
the whole thing but if you want to live
in a pluralistic society okay I did not
get any hate from anyone on the right by
the way before this I got literally
hundreds if not thousands of emails and
certainly thousands of tweets basically
people just saying Dave I love the book
I'm just not with you on the abortion
one but it's all good and most of them
say what you kind of said which is well
you'll get there so you'll get there
what is something like that okay but
putting that aside I think there will be
a certain set within that that'll be
like no no no that's a bridge too far
and I think what's happening is a lot of
the disaffected lefties they're going I
can never call myself a conservative
because of the abortion one that for
them sure is is like the one that that
scares them and keep them in the cross
and on the other side well one of the
great political thinkers Cardinal
Manning said that at bottom all religion
or all political conflict and all human
conflict is theological it comes down to
religious questions and you know st.
Andrew Breitbart the patron of Hollywood
conservative yes he had a similar saying
which is politics is downstream of
culture and then and then we know that
cult and culture come from the same root
word the what a culture worships defines
that culture and so at the bottom you
have these religious questions and some
people write off religious questions and
they say well I science well in the way
that these modern liberals are using the
word science it's a synonym they're
using in the same way to talk about
eternal questions and the question is
what is a human being what is a human
being for and what does a just politics
do to innocent human beings so I would
imagine that years ago you would have
called yourself more pro-choice than
you do now oh yeah certainly if you've
come over in it how could I be upset
that you've come closer to my opinion on
the question of abortion now why would I
be angry about that that you in my view
have become more correct on that
question well I always tell been when
I've debated this with him I always like
listen you're making good arguments but
it's the bananas left these that are
pushing me out right when they say you
can't be you can't be pro-life and be a
Democrat or when they say you can have
an abortion at eight months it's like I
got nothing to negotiate with you guys
over there at least with you guys I mean
Glenn Beck who of courses is pro-life
I've discussed this many times with him
and and even though we've come to
different conclusions I find our logic
actually is the same to get there in
many ways you know it I mean it's like
we're both trying to keep the state out
of people's lives and then we can talk
about life and all that but that so I
think I get your your conclusion there
because it's like all right we can at
least do something here yeah but if
you're gonna tell me that at an 8-month
abortion but just because someone feels
like it is okay it's crazy what can I do
what can I do and and talk about using
every every tool available to us you
know we're talking about that with big
tech well you can apply it the same way
here I think the philosophical arguments
for abortion or extraordinarily weak I
don't think they're much of arguments at
all I think all of the arguments against
abortion are very strong philosophically
theologically it's not even close it's
not even a question and then there are
scientific arguments and it's hard to
make scientific arguments because what
are you gonna say okay when the when the
baby has its right arm then it's
deserves not to be killed but what
before it has its right arm then it
deserves to be killed I don't that's not
very compelling by the way I don't know
if you read my book but I do make that
concession right I do make that
concession of course so when you see it
I think to me this is even more
important maybe than the arguments and
this is where science plays a role in it
because of the advance of sight of
medical technology you can see the baby
you can send this is why I think you
would say you see the thing the baby at
eight weeks you say I can't kill that I
can't that's I can look at that and see
that that's a human being maybe you can
see that at seven months maybe you say
it's six months maybe you see all
way back to me that's that's very
persuasive because don't forget we're
not just brains floating in the air
right politics it's not just pure
philosophy floating in the air we're
human beings we're flesh and blood we're
moved by images and those images I think
are very helpful and if some of those
images move you all the way back to 12
weeks to me that's something worth
celebrating and maybe now then we can go
a little bit further too so with that
very pleasant way you describe that with
the smile on your face I won't talk
about civility a little bit because
somebody actually not realizing that I
was having you on the show today yeah
somebody in the Rubin report community
put up a post about civility and they
said they said Dave you and Michael
knowles are two of the best at it that's
very nice so there you go somebody likes
you great but but basically what they
were saying in terms of debates because
you have a zillion videos of you
debating leftist and all those things
and you don't you don't put them down
you know you occasionally do some jokes
and and that kind of stuff but you do
engage in ideas I've never seen you
unless there's something I haven't seen
I've never seen you try to destroy
somebody or any of the rest of that
stuff where do you think civility from
you comes from because do you think it's
just sort of temperament coupled with
knowing what you're talking about or do
you think it's one or the other more or
something else I think politics is much
more pleasant if you begin from a place
of humility
now our politics starts from a place of
pride right proper I'm I've got to get
my way about everything and if you don't
give me everything I want even a little
bit I'm gonna burn your city to the
ground that's what we've been seeing or
at least start my own city within your
city or in store at least start my own
yeah and build a lot of walls and start
a police force and only some yeah so I
think it's good to begin with humility
because especially I mean you'd be a
great example of this you've changed
your mind on a lot of issues I've
changed my mind on a lot of issues so
when I'm debating some left winger
whether it's a 22 year old college kid
or whether it's a 52 year old Democrat
who goes on cable news I can look at
that person and say there but for the
grace of God go I maybe maybe
I would have thought that thing if I
hadn't had this conversation ten years
ago with this person I was I was in
favor of abortion until I had lunch with
a bioethicists
and she convinced me my arguments were
wrong then I changed my mind
so I think well maybe I could have that
influence down the line on somebody else
III don't get angry really in politics
you know there's an expression don't get
mad get even
yeah and if I can I'll get even yeah you
are I am Italian you know these are
important rules thank you just one not
two years old to me that that's much
more productive it's just not my style
really to you know smack somebody or
ruin them or get really personal or any
I just don't I don't care that much I
want them to come around to the right
point of view I want to have a good
politics but I I don't need to pull my
hair out and ruin my life for that I
mean don't freak this is still our life
you know and if you're gonna spend it
being miserable and angry all the time
you're probably doing it wrong yeah is
that the most dangerous thing in a way
that these people these lefties who now
have become religious in their in their
anti religion they've become religious
and they're anti racism they've become
racist but that their whole worldview is
politics like it is what what what do
you guys have besides politics I would
you know I try not to tweet on the
weekends in Corona it has not been going
well no because now we don't know when
weekends are right what is the weekend
but like a skate you know I do my August
off-the-grid thing like getting out of
the day-to-day minutia I view as it's
like more I can't imagine how important
it is right now you know people get
angry when they don't know what they're
talking about people who know what
they're talking about tend not to get
angry because very often they know what
you're about to say they kind of know
that argument and they can refute the
counter arguments so they've just done
it before they see where this is going
the people burning down cities the
people screaming at you on Twitter or
wherever they don't know what they're
talking about
just from a at a practical level when
you get angry you don't think as clearly
and I know there have been a few times
I've done it where I mean I I like to
think I can count them on one
where I've sent an angry tweet mm-hmm I
said I wasn't gonna tweet on the weekend
and I got something got me really like
an I tweeted those are the only tweets I
regret yeah there's the only tweets that
I've sent that I think I don't actually
stand by that I don't really it's just
from a long scale of your life it's not
gonna be good if you live your life
angry all the time but even just from a
tactical position in politics if that's
the way you're conducting politics
you're gonna you're gonna make more
mistakes so since we've talked a lot
about the Conservatives and we've talked
about just sort of like the general
lefty lunacy that's going on let's just
do a little bit on like the political
side what's happening with the Democrats
yeah well first off do you think Biden's
gonna be the nominee just simple yes or
no I
I watched him yesterday wearing he was
wearing a mask this was a while ago he
was wearing a mask
dangling from his ear it wasn't on his
face it didn't go to the other ear was
just dangling down that's not going to
protect him from the virus so just from
a practical medical perspective I think
he's gonna figure out do the mask he's
not gonna do it he doesn't seem like
he's in it for the long run however you
without getting conspiratorial about
anything there's a master plan to kick
him out at the convention who who are
they gonna replace him with I mean he
ran against what was it 25 or 27 other
people and he beat them all I get that
he's a horrific candidate but I I don't
really see anyone replacing him what do
you think well I mean I've been saying
for months now I think that the plan
sort of was we just get through the
election to get him there and then he's
not in charge and this guy he obvious I
mean this other thing where they just
simply the mainstream media simply
refuses to talk about his cognitive
decline yeah it's like that is a type of
fake news we all see something and you
guys won't let us see it but so so
that's one thing so I think I don't know
you bring in Elizabeth Warren or net
well now I know you know he'll obviously
bring in a black woman so it's like all
right do you bring in condi rice look
condi rice I think it's actually way
better yeah
not condi rice sorry you just did a
racist I did you did a racism here we go
who the hell am I talking you've got
canceled my episode because my
Who am I talking about not Susan Rice
Susan Rice right I'd be pretty good
maybe I could I can wait no I I could I
could vote for condi rice Susan Rice is
making a play for it she's writing New
York Times op eds
yes which you know Susan Rice could be
in things they're all the same that city
but this was more of a rice issue that
was a rice issue you know he was never a
Jerry Rice right that's true
whew that was close yeah you know we
don't edit for content I mean that could
be a more serious choice because yeah
the other the other options for women
they said any Klobuchar and you Club you
char has some baggage when it comes to
criminal justice come up Kamala Harris
says the same thing Stacey Abrams is a
punch line she is not she is best known
for losing an election before that she
was a Georgia state rep come on give me
a break
yeah so you know Susan Rice would be a
real choice the other problem Biden has
is often you want to balance a ticket so
you got the conservative Reagan and
you've got that more establishment more
liberal George Bush because we see the
cognitive decline of Joe Biden I don't
think that's gonna work you it's not
it's not going to make Biden voters feel
better if there's some radical leftist
on the ticket you've got to have a
candidate who's just kind of a younger
perhaps black or perhaps more feminine
perhaps whatever version of Joe Biden a
more establishment candidate and someone
like rice would fit that bill right the
only problem with that though is that
then the base of these radical lunatics
will gladly destroy the entire party
which i think is gonna happen either way
yeah you know you mean like you could
pick mini Biden to stave it off but that
only delays it slightly or you picked
what you wanted the crazies and
congratulations
now you've burned the whole thing down
so either way it's it's just a movement
of destruction I think it's like it's
like it's inevitable and basically I
just think the Democratic Party is over
like the Socialists have taken over in
effect you know but you the thing you
got to remember about the Democratic
Party is its endured for a long time you
know as they say they're the longest
living extant political party in the
world
and part of the reason they're good is
because they don't have a ton of
principles you know this is why they
they're able to last Bill Clinton a man
who believes in nothing right he runs as
a left-winger like cigars a you're a
cigar guy I am NOT okay I'm not second
so he runs as a liberal you know a left
winger in the early 90s then by the end
of the nineties he says the era of big
government is over why because he lost
the midterm election and Newt Gingrich
took over the house
he has no principles he'll go whichever
way the wind blows Joe Biden is it is in
many ways this kind of a candidate Joe
Biden had an actually pretty good crime
bill in the 1990s which would probably
be the most popular thing he could run
on right now and yet he's running it
away from it and Trump is hammering him
for it that shows you how crazy our
politics it's gotten yeah well he's
running away from all his old position
he's running away from his old abortion
positions that were more moderate right
you know and also correct me if I'm
wrong but he was vice president am I
right on that ah no he's a knee and he
was in the Senate for like 50 years no
you know what it is this time
now incredible now he can affect you
have you seen that meme where it's like
the you know Biden's been in for 40
years Schumer's been in for 40 years
Pelosi has been in since the 1600s like
it's like it's like oh you guys are all
going to suddenly do all this I'm gonna
say you said I've been trying not to say
it because I think that usually gets us
D Monica it's just a simple a simple
curse word we all just look freaks yeah
they're always oh well I'm worried I got
you on I'm done anyway but but like the
people that like fall for it like what
is that people that fall for it every
single freaking time so this is what
shows you what Trump is up against
because Trump is a weird candidate right
Trump is in no way part of a Republican
establishment I don't think the guy was
a Republican for much of his life yeah
and he comes in and he has shaken things
up in a way that other Republicans were
not able to do in the way he speaks in
the way he looks at immigration and the
way he looks at trade in the way he
looks at other matters of foreign policy
all sorts of things what you get
reminded of when you see a Pelosi or a
Clinton or a Biden or or a Schumer that
is the establishment
the Liberals the progressives they are
the establishment and they're pretending
to be the subversive culture but
actually they control everything and the
establishment knows how to protect
itself okay and the minute that you have
someone like a trump who comes in and
says I want to change this a little bit
you have the full weight of the
bureaucracy of the Democratic
establishment of the Republican
establishment which in many ways just
plays the foil to the Democratic
establishment they lose with grace that
sort of thing they turn all of their
guns on that guy it's the most Radek
ironically it's the most radical moment
of politics that I think any of us have
seen in our lifetime so I'm with you on
that even for my differences on Trump
like I do believe that is the allure of
Trump and and that is in it a nutshell
I'm curious because you've become
friendly with Ted Cruz and you guys do a
podcast trunk was pretty relentless on
him in the campaign and yet he's become
one of trumps biggest allies now in many
ways I always when I see well Cruz has
also become a great Twitter person he
gets it he gets memes he's funny he gets
Star Wars references like he's Foote he
fully gets it now and I actually regret
being so Auntie Cruz because there was
just something about him that I didn't
like it was just too stodgy for me or
something but since you've listened to
the podcast you know that's a great guy
he is a good guy he's funny I think he's
the constitutional conservative in the
way that I can get on board all that
stuff yeah have you guys talked about
how he's been able to put some of the
that stuff aside like the personal
attacks that Trump did on him and sure
and the rest of it like well you know we
started the podcast the the verdict
podcast during impeachment so this is
the hottest moment of the Trump
presidency I mean this is where everyone
is attacking him you even had a couple
of Republicans trying to turn on him and
gain support to throw them out of office
too and here you have senator Cruz a
former opponent of President Trump now
you know good stale word conservative in
the Senate defending him and really what
Cruz is doing is defending the
Constitution I mean you even you had
some liberals people like Alan
Dershowitz who came out and said I am
defending the Constitution here it is
not constitutional for you to try to
throw this guy out of office and
I think it's something I really admire
about senator Cruz his look political
campaigns get hot people say a lot of
terrible things they get and and if you
want to accomplish something you can't
take that stuff personally you can't
hold personal grudges like that and so
I've really admired the way that you
have it there's a tough campaign you put
it behind you and you you try to get the
work done because one thing I've noticed
having spent a little bit of time in
Washington doing this show and for other
for other projects is a lot of people
who go to Washington don't care about
accomplishing anything they don't they
want to be a congressman they want to be
a senator they don't want to do anything
that that involves and when you do
things and I've heard this I heard this
from the president's chief of staff just
a week ago on the verdict show when you
do things you don't get invited to
cocktail parties when you do things
people are very mean to you and they
ostracize you and you kick you out but
what's the point why else go it's not
that glamorous of life and so I you know
III think Cruz could not have acted
better you know since since 2016 and I'm
glad at least there's one or two
conservatives in the Senate because a
lot of people go wishy-washy yeah all
right I got one more for your nose which
I think will tie this up in a nice
little bow let's see if we can do it all
right as somebody that now is in this
world of pundit Rhee like we are so in
the center of the center of everything
right now the things that we talk about
the things that we've been talking about
we started to build relationships with
some of these people like you are now
friends with Ted Cruz like how much of
all of this seems completely surreal to
you because I do wake up sometimes and
I'm like I can't believe you know from
from where any of us started from where
I when I started doing a little YouTube
thing or even before that I had a I had
a podcast like 10 years ago before when
I didn't even know how to download
podcasts I kid you not I don't even know
what a podcast was but now we're like
right in the center of this very strange
thing that everyone is talking about
just curious how sort of how that fills
your life that's personally very
exciting but this has been surreal for
me for a few years and it's been surreal
for me since oh wait
this joke you know and then I did this
it's joke yes it was now there's only
about three years ago I was a blank book
basically just it is literally
completely for the people watching it is
a blank book reasons to vote for
Democrats and and incredible by the way
some of the suburbs that you got here
Dennis Prager read this twice that's
impressive he is seriously busy
insightful yet remarkably easy reading
guy Benson just just wonderfully well
thank you for them but yeah you know I
published this blank book I
self-published did it just isn't show
yeah to irritate my Democrat friends and
then the thing jumps and becomes the
number one bestseller in the world for
like what we can have yeah so I think
I'm the only guy in the history of
politics to get a show for not writing a
book right so that and I thought that
was actually a great way for that to
happen because we were talking about
religion earlier it's a great example of
unearned grace you know you laugh you
like literally don't do anything and
then you get a lot of great stuff for it
so yes personally it's very exciting but
I think politically publicly it's very
exciting too because the reason the book
took off is because of this weird
political moment that we're in right
well a lot of the reason the book took
off is because all the people who bought
it lefties really long deep reviews of
it comparing it to float fair and all
these kind of really funny things right
yeah that humor really came from the
audience
same thing with Trump right I think we
just love that we've cracked this stale
dead political establishment consensus
there's something new happening even if
we don't always like what it lifts kind
of scary it's a little weird but we like
that it's happening you know if what
we're doing couldn't have happened
twenty years ago what we would not be
possible we're living in a world now
where a corrupt mainstream media that
has lied through its teeth and then it
slide through its teeth about lying
through his teeth for decades is a is a
punchline people don't watch it the only
people who watch CNN or walking through
airports we're living in a world in
which that kind of silly political talk
that use you saw from candidates this
time around like Pete Buddha jej or you
hear it from some of the older
establishment politicians they say well
you know I I believe in this not that
I believe in this not that you and you
read and you listen to it you say well
what does that really mean because I
know he can't mean this I know he has to
write that's gone and now we're living
in the blunt direct world of the way the
Trump talks or the way that other people
talk that to me is is what some so much
more exciting we've got this this
realignment where now instead of having
to go through the gatekeeper of the
anchor on ABC news who's talking to the
establishment guy who's ya know some guy
with a podcast can go talk to some of
the most powerful people on earth and
you can get a message out that is very
different from that which has been
approved by the liberal establishment to
me as exciting as it is personally to me
politically that's the much more
exciting fact Knolls that was a nice
ending but there is one other thing I
have to do lighten up because as you
were the last person whose hand I shook
that then you know I never got Corona
now we've done this yeah and either way
we could be passing it one another so I
just wanted to be on camera here it is
that and I think that's a felony in
California and we just did oh no
Garcetti is outside the car is don't
worry about that it's been a pleasure
chatting with you as always it's at
Michael J Knowles on Twitter yeah all
right that's right all right that's it
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell